all right it's Friday again time for
another movie retrospective and here's
one I've been wanting to do for a really
really really really really long time
and we're finally getting around to
doing it yep
this is 1973's the wicker man not the
new one you guys yeah I have it I have
not been able to bring myself I've seen
shoe clips of it you know but I haven't
been able to like bring myself to watch
it it was bad yeah bad yeah it ruined
what the ruined what the original one
was about yeah yeah I mean the original
one had a message and it really wasn't
carried over they just kind of in the
new one they made it kind of like a
cheesy horror flick that didn't make a
whole lot of sense compared to the old
one if you knew what the old one was
about yeah we'll talk a little bit about
analysis of this story and what it meant
yeah yeah
towards the end it's really it's
interesting because it almost seemed
like there was some kind of curse
against this movie like for a really
long time it was like a really tortured
like production how it kind of came
about was you know Christopher Lee
obviously was very famous for doing
Hammer movies playing Dracula and things
like that and he kind of wanted to get
out of that because he was afraid he was
getting typecast so he started talking
to um the screenwriter of this his last
name is Shaffer I camera what his first
name was and also the director Robin
Hardy now I think this was Robin Hardy's
first movie before the he was a
playwright and he'd done like some
theater productions and stuff so they
decided they had this idea we're like we
want to do something about like old time
like folk religion like old pagan
religions because that was something
that didn't get put in a lot of horror
type movies although he doesn't really I
mean Christopher Lee is you know we
didn't really consider it a horror movie
it's kind of more a thriller I guess you
would call it like a mystery now this
movie here it influenced a lot of people
actually kind of like in some of the
early goth scenes
yeah like death and June and well
actually he's like guys for like David
Tibet and Douglas nature an organization
lot of bands have covered it was not in
the early protocol scene there was kind
of a weird merger of of kind of like
Celtic mythology
folklore and when you told my Nicholas
Pearce kind of like German Road magic it
was all kind of they were trying they
were kind of rejecting in a certain way
the the Christian establishment and kind
of embracing the old ways of Europe you
know and this movie kind of I thinking
spurred on a lot of young people to kind
of study these kinds of religions and
try to understand what they meant and
how they correlated to to today to the
modern era yeah it's interesting period
this is kind of like it's considered
sort of one of the you know there was
kind of a couple years in there where
there were a couple of what they call
British folk horror movies the other
ones that are named are usually
Witchfinder general which came out in
1968 and also blood on Satan's claw
which came out in 1971 which actually I
really liked a lot I liked Witchfinder
general too but blood on Satan's Clyro
like a big long thing about it on my
blog because I really like that movie
and I feel like it's underappreciated
but so as I said so Christopher Lee and
the screenwriter and the director wanted
to do something about pagan religion in
Scotland or somewhere in the UK so there
was this novel written by a guy I think
his name is David Penner and it came out
in 1967 1968 it was called the ritual
and it had a similar story to what ended
up being the wicker man but after you
know the screenwriter read it he's like
okay well I'm gonna use the germ of this
you know it still had to do with like a
Christian going to this island and there
was all these pagans and all this
horrible [ __ ] happen but he kind of like
changed the story up a little bit
interestingly and I don't think you knew
this so you might find this interesting
the title and the image of the wicker
man that actually came from the
screenwriter I believe bread was reading
Julius Caesar's account of the Gallic
Wars and there was like a sentence in
there where he was talking about these
villagers like in parts of what is now
France and that's how they would get rid
of their convicted criminals they would
construct like a wooden man like a big
one and put a guy in there and set him
on fire so that's where that whole
imagery came from so that's not like
specific to that part of sky
where the movie takes place but I just
thought that was interesting that it
just came from well they came from
Julius Caesar that's where that and
because that image is so iconic I think
that's like the best-known part of this
movie which I feel like got a little bit
forgotten it didn't really start getting
a cult following until the 80s and you
know what's weird is that even though
nowadays it's considered one of the best
British horror movies ever made for a
time it didn't even really get a general
release in the UK what ended up
happening was like I said the production
was really troubled Christopher Lee and
a lot of the cast and crew were really
excited to work on it they thought it
was a great script
which it is and so a lot of whom worked
for very little or no money the the
story was supposed to be set in spring
but they had to film it in October so
they were all freezing their asses off
um although you can't really tell in the
movie they had to have like plastic
trees and plastic flowers and stuff
because everything was like barren and
dead because they filmed it way up in
Scotland it was really cold um [ __ ] like
that but then when the film was done I
think the British lion production was
like the production company that had
made it it had been bought out by EMI so
EMI executives came to see the cut of it
and we're like yeah we don't like that
like they're like you have to take they
told me take like 20 minutes out they
also told Robin Hardy's changed the
ending to make it like a happier ending
they're like well shouldn't the guy get
saved or shouldn't like come and reign
and put the fire out or whatever and
Robin was like no we're not doing that
so he stuck to his guns on that he did
make some cuts to it and so began this
whole saga of like there are so many
versions like I've seen online that
either the original cut was as much as
two hours long or it was a hundred and
two minutes but then they made for the
UK release they made them cut it down to
87 minutes
they didn't take out anything because
it's not gory or anything like that but
they just took out like a bunch of
character scenes and [ __ ] like that it
was nothing that was this movie's a slow
burner it has a very yellow build up
like I said it's more mystery yeah you
it's not really structured like a horror
movie no not at all it's not a horror
movie
really so you really have to stick with
this one it almost kind of feels like a
documentary and a police investigation
movie all kind of happened yeah and a
musical sort of showing both more you
know yeah it does have a backstory it
does have a was an overarching theme to
it and once you get to the end and you
think about it you know - I'll probably
talk about it later once you start
thinking about the meaning of the movie
you go oh okay I see I see what they're
what they're telling me and I really
didn't catch I really didn't catch the
meaning of it until I saw a guy's
analysis of it which I was like oh of
course that's what it means
yeah and I was able to kind of see some
more than it's more to it than even what
he saw these are the young guy but
there's like really only one analysis
I've seen yeah well I've read a lot of
different analysis of this movie you
know not a lot of ones on video several
different cuts this movie now there's a
an interview with Christopher Lee and he
said that you know he's made almost 300
movies like 270 and he said that out of
all of them this one was his favorite
and he considered it to be a masterpiece
but the commonly viewed edit is not his
not the real edit yeah that's that
wasn't his favorite one that there was
another edit that he liked a lot better
and he was he thought it was out there
somewhere and was hoping that it would
emerge and I thought somebody had that
original cut well it turns out somebody
did have it it was found in the
possessions of what's-his-name Roger
Corman Roger Corman Roger Sherman had it
because the production company sent him
and it actually wasn't the entire cut it
was a 99 minute cut okay and it got sent
to Roger Corman because they wanted him
to try to distribute it like for driving
but it had some of the missing stuff in
it yeah okay so he had it for a long
time I think he later gave it to like
the Harvard Film Institute I think was
where they ended up finding it but the
interesting thing like I said it didn't
really get a general release in the UK
sometimes like it got a couple theaters
it
usually like put on a double bill with
don't look now which we really have to
do a review because that's one of my
favorite movies in the 1970s so it was
kind of like the B picture to that but
interestingly because it went to the US
and I think the 99 minute version was
actually making the rounds and you know
drive-ins and stuff so it actually had a
much bigger audience and a much bigger
cult following in the u.s. than it did
in its native country for a really long
time but over the years like it's you
know reputation grew and then finally
like you know in the 80's 90's you know
the UK started getting like the more ya
director's cut and stuff like that and
sort of appreciated it more I don't
think we've actually mentioned what this
movies about a fuse never seen this it's
about a British cop who gets a message
or a lead on a missing-persons case out
from on this remote island and when he
gets to this island he starts asking
around if anybody had seen this girl
he's got a photograph of her you know
and and everyone's denying that this
girl even exists when he gets there and
it's this quaint little village on an
island you know and all the people there
are kind of taunting and toying with him
and he turns out that they're not
Christians that there are some kind of a
pre-christian cult and this cop is a
devout Christian and their ways are very
different than his their culture and
their beliefs structure is very
different you know it's very much kind
of like a free love type society crowded
in the earth it's hippie but not really
it's it's got kind of a dark side to it
you know very traditional seeming or
traditional feeling kind of you know
pre-christian Europe type vibe going on
there dressing up in costumes they have
a green man maple all eight holes and so
he gets kind of wigged out on this and
it turns out that that girl never
existed yes or she did exist but she
wasn't actually missing and they had
sent him this bum lead and this bum
report of her disappearance because they
were trying to lure him there because he
was the perfect candidate
this sacrifice that they wanted to do to
help bring the apples back and the way
it is you know everybody knows where
this big old Wicker Man and set him on
fire and he's praying to God and cursing
them you know and they're all singing
these happy folk songs why he's burning
up and when I first saw the movie I
thought it was just kinda that it had a
striking end to it but I thought it was
just kind of first kind of like a kind
of a a movie that kind of put pagan
morality above Christian morality but as
time goes on and after I've heard a
couple of other lore that one guy's
analysis I see that just there was a lot
more to it yeah that is not the case
that's not what it was about it wasn't
saying that paganism was better than
Christianity was saying that
Christianity was paganism it says the
word that they were both they were about
the same thing they were just different
it was about religious delusion yeah
that's really what it was about and an
interesting thing that this movie it is
I was one of the best things about this
movie like I said the final like 20
minutes of it are like super horrific
when how he realizes that he's been
played this entire time you know and he
sees the Wicker Man for the first time
you realizes what's gonna happen and
it's just this horrifying image and like
you know when the head falls off at the
end and this the Sun is behind it and
everything but I think one of the
coolest things about this movie is that
from the beginning
sergeant Howie's character he's played
by Edward Woodward who up until then he
was actually a famous TV actor in the UK
and then he became a very famous TV
actor in the u.s. later on because he
was on the equalizer in the 80s but he
plays sergeant Howie as a really
unsympathetic character this is one of
the things that I think makes the movie
work so well because he's so
stick-in-the-mud he's so uptight he
doesn't have a sense of humor he comes
to this island and essentially starts
throwing his weight around you know what
I mean cuz he's from the law and he's
like what do you you can't have this pub
open you can't have this you can't have
he's a virgin he's like really so he's
never married Susan ever had sex yes so
this
the character this is a protagonist that
you're seeing you know the whole entire
story through and initially when he
first comes to summer Isle and he meets
Christopher Lee playing lurid summer
I'll and he meets all the locals they
seemed initially they're kind of playful
because everyone's like Rowan Morrison
who's that way there's no missing girl I
don't know what you're talking about and
they seem but they seem playful they
seem happy they seem joyous they seem a
lot more sympathetic than him yeah
they're also very kind of animalistic
they just kind of yeah have sex
yeah just outdoors and stuff like that
like you know the best-looking the
best-looking girl in town screws all the
guys yeah I know it's you know doesn't
charge of or anything just screwed as
well you know and then they sing songs
about it yeah that she's a hoe
you know yeah so like I said in some
ways because Howie is so repressed you
initially find yourself sympathizing
with the pagans at first but then this
is kind of this is like a trap much like
the one that has been set for Howie
because as the movie goes on it gets
more and more sinister until you finally
realize I've been sympathizing with the
villains yeah the whole time even as as
unsympathetic as Howie's character is he
ends up being the victim yeah and even
though I've seen some reviews saying so
even though he was right well maybe he's
morally right because he doesn't believe
in human sacrifice but as far as their
religious beliefs go neither one of them
are right yeah there's a bunch of
delusion going on right moralistic
delusion about really the only what you
can break the movie down in is what was
true was is before they're getting ready
to sacrifice him he says killing me
isn't gonna bring your apple crop back
yeah there's the reason why the Apple
crops failed is because the people the
guy who established this island brought
fruit from outside this temperate zone
you know I mean and tried to get it to
grow in a place where it can't grow over
life it works for a while so your crops
are gonna fail sometimes bringing
killing me will not bring the
drops back so then they sticking him in
there and put him on fire and he starts
praying to God to be reborn and you know
he's preaching which kind of is showing
that there was another delusion he
believes that he's gonna be reborn after
death because he because it because he
believes in this religion and he
believes that in the same way that those
people who are killing him believe that
the crops will be reborn with his with
his which is death so basically what
what it meant the deeper meaning is is
that yea the crops will come back but it
won't have anything to do with these
this pagan religion they'll just come
back on their own yeah and yeah maybe
after this guy dies he might be in some
kind of afterlife but it doesn't have
anything to do with his religion yeah
yeah that's really what it says
religions are delusions yeah I think the
end of it pretty fairly shows that that
it's like you know yes it's horrible
what they were doing to him but he's not
right either
I mean his belief isn't right he's right
if he comes back or if he comes better
if he is reborn into an afterlife it
won't have anything to do with his
religion yeah you know if those crops
are reborn it won't have anything to do
it their religion that's what that's
what they're talking about yeah it's
just it's kind of showing like that
nature's running this not that yeah that
it's like you're trying to impose your
will on something upon who's you know
you can't impose your will upon it
because like much larger than Yale yeah
and it'd kind of say that it did kind of
say that the that the Islanders they're
they're their pagan system did kind of
allow them to live in kind of a more
natural state yeah but they were also
deluded sure I mean they weren't
bringing crops back through human
sacrifice so yeah you know and it also
is kind of saying in a way that you know
when you're talking about you know the
crucifixion scenes and Catholicism and
the way that it's set up it's basically
saying that Catholicism is just another
form of pagan and religion yeah from it
so the movies really kind of saying
you know there isn't much difference
between the two they're both a delusion
that's what it's saying well I'm like I
said you know aside from that which like
I said you don't even really need to
pick up on that to like enjoy the movie
because really it's kind of like like I
said I don't I wouldn't call it a pure
horror movie it's more of like a mystery
thriller type thing or policing role
because behind it with the philosophy
behind it it's like the whole time Howie
is trying to figure out what's going on
with this missing girl cuz he knows like
what all these weirdos they're hiding
something because at first they're
saying
Rowen you know who what are you talking
about she's there's no one here by that
name but then when he finds out that she
does exist and then she then he starts
oh well maybe she's dead maybe this then
the other thing and then he thinks that
she's gonna be the sacrifice but then
like I said at the end he finds out that
he's been manipulated the whole time and
there's some just really great imagery
in this like this there's just one point
where he's in the school classroom and
he opened up
Rowan's desk and inside the desk there's
like a nail and there's like a beetle
and it's tied to a string and the beetle
is like walking around the string yeah
you know what I mean and he's just
tightened and tight just like the plot
is tightening around him you know kind
of that's gonna be his doom at the end
and he's just been led along this path
the whole entire time because they have
you know they figured they really need a
big sacrifice because you know they're
their crops have been bountiful up until
now but then it failed this one
particular year so they needed the big
guns they need a really big good
sacrifice so they determined that he was
like the best one because he met all
this criteria so they just engineered
this huge plot yeah to get him there and
then you know you're told a backstory by
the character of Christopher Lee's plays
what was his name Lord samurai or some
summer Isle that's yeah well because
that's the name that's in there his
grandfather set all this up and he kind
of purged it of Christian thinking and
kind of brought back kind of pagan
beliefs and bred a bunch of plants that
could grow there so the island could be
self-sufficient so they're growing
apples and I guess fruit YES on an
island where it shouldn't be growing you
know
you kind of freedom from there you know
restrictive Christianity so that's why
all this stuff is there yeah it's not
happening in a vacuum and it wasn't some
kind of hold over from the medieval
period it had only been doing this for a
few generations yeah I think yeah it had
been three generations because it was it
was Lord Summer Isles grandfather that
did it man the kiddies being buried
today and they didn't really have much
contact with the outside world they
controlled who came yeah and the
interesting thing too is the private
property you know yeah well yeah because
it was a family yeah that was his like
fiefdom or whatever but the interesting
thing too is that one of the things that
sergeant Howie says to Lord summer Isle
is that oh you brought all these you
know genetically altered essentially
fruits and you know to make them grow
where they're not supposed to grow and
it's against nature but in some ways
sergeant Howie the way he is is against
nature too because he's very repressed
he's engaged to a girl but if they
haven't had sex he's like 40
I think the actor was 42 in the movie 42
year old yeah 42 year old virgin which
yes but but that's also against nature
kind of legend the sacrifice had to be
act like a king he had to be a fool and
he had to be a virgin and pure of heart
in all concert in a fool because yeah
they engineered it so that he would end
up dressed as punch and yeah and as
they're as they're burning him up
they're kind of making sure that he's
dying the death of a Christian martyr
stuff like that what's that kind of
played in with it too yeah it's a great
movie it's most people would say this
movie was probably a masterpiece of what
it was trying to do yeah it's it's
really it's it's really good because the
whole thing is the way the whole thing
is shot it's pretty much all shot in the
daytime like in this really bright flat
like almost documentary style yeah um
which actually sort of makes it
unsettling because if you've never seen
it before and like at night
stop I know she's not doing it she
turned plays bar yeah cuz you're not
entirely sure like what's going on and
like what's up with this missing girl
and everything and then the tension just
gets tighter and tighter and tighter
until there's just like completely
horrific ending and it's unusual in that
they didn't usually end move
that way in the sense Ian you know what
I mean it would be like the EMI
executives saying you know we'll
shouldn't somebody come and save him or
shouldn't something happen you know so
that does it yes so the ending does it
end the way it ends but they were like
no they didn't pull back that's just
that's the way it ends if you want to
wreck the meeting then the credits roll
yeah like like the Nicolas Cage one did
wreck the meaning of the movie although
he died at the end of that one too yeah
yeah but they didn't really have the
whole religious delusion it doesn't work
the same because I feel like one the
Nicolas Cage one was transplanted to
like some island off Washington State
they made the society like matriarchal
um you know committee man versus woman
well compared so it was like bees so the
men were drones and that kind of said
they had that whole thing going on but
they didn't have I don't know there's
there's just something it doesn't work
the same because we don't have the
tradition of like this Celtic or pagan
you know of you know religions of old
Europe we don't really have an
equivalent of that that kind of plays
the same so I don't think it really
worked out I think in the remake they
made it like this matriarchal said oh
they were all like they were in Salem
and they were persecuted for being
witches or something said they ran out
to this island so I think there was some
explanation for that but it just it
doesn't work the same and plus if you've
seen the original I mean the story is
fairly is pretty much the same so you
know what's gonna happen so it's not a
sense of you know a mystery or anything
because you already know that Nicholas
Cage got brought to the island because
they were gonna sacrifice him so there's
no surprise there there's no suspense
there and it's just it seemed like the
whole thing was dumb now an interesting
thing is that there have actually been a
couple of attempts to do like a sequel
to the original wicker man I think Robin
Hardy or no the the original
screenwriter Shafer he wrote a script
called something about the Lambton worm
which is another kind of Scottish folk
legend and it was gonna be
he wrote a script for it and it was
gonna be like more of a fantasy type
thing but that never got made I guess a
lot of people didn't like it and I think
that script was supposed to hinge on the
fact that Sargent how he did survive the
Wicker Man which the director was like
it was supposed to die at the end you
know that's just how it works and we're
not doing a thing we're oh well they
show they pretty much show him dying I
don't see how yeah that's what I mean so
it just seemed very like just I thought
of that line for misery he didn't get
out of the cockadoody car you know what
I mean so that's that kind of thing
happened now they did actually make a
sequel I think or a spiritual sequel
they call it I think it was in 2011 it
was same director Robin Hardy
Christopher Lee had a cameo in it it was
called the willow tree it was actually I
think it was willow tree or wicker tree
the wicker tree sir yes I thought I was
thinking of something else the wicker
tree and I was thinking a willow the
character yeah Britt Ekland play
original movie but but yeah so it's kind
of it's set in the same it's set in like
a pagan Scottish village same kind of
deal but this time it's like two
American like evangelists that come
there with their purity ring's and all
this other kind of stuff to like to
convert the heathens and things go
predictably from there I haven't seen it
but I've heard it's really really not
very good although in light of the 2006
Nicolas Cage remake I'm sure it probably
it couldn't be any worse than that and
just running around punching people they
never should have remade the movie no
that's what I mean it's just it was such
a product of its time and also a product
of its culture that I just don't think
you can translate it doesn't it just
doesn't translate to an American you try
to take that wicker math story and
update it for a modern American audience
it's just not gonna work because the
Wicker Man is kind of a slow kind of
chilled out movie it's not really
interesting by today's standards you
have to get about halfway through it
before it started you start kind of get
pulled into it it does have it does have
its own its tone its ambience you know
that means yeah it is weird vibe it's
not modern not a lotta movies
estrangement yet and I feel like and I
read this so hard to put it in time
there's nothing it's a set made in the
set
but there's nothing about it that lets
you know that it's a 70s movie it's just
you know it's almost kind of like an art
movie in a way yet like the only thing
the only thing I can kind of compare it
to in terms of tone be Zardoz in a
certain way just not as bizarre but yeah
the free-flowing there was like they
were making it up as everything along I
think they were yeah yeah and wicker man
feels like they're making it up as
they're going along but they're not
towards the end you go hey they're not
really making this up yeah because it's
there because they show you a bunch of
scenes that you're not really sure why
they showed you that then later you but
everything is there for everything's
there for like I said because everything
was engineered from the beginning yeah
so when you go back and watch it again
you're like oh okay that's what yeah it
doesn't explicitly tell you what these
things mean yeah they're showing you you
just got to wait
but yeah so like I said if I feel sad
for you if all you've seen is the
Nicolas Cage remake because you really
need to go back and watch the person
because the interesting thing and I was
reading a review today where somebody
said you know the Wicker Man almost
seemed to come out of a vacuum it's like
it wasn't like inspired by any movie
before it really you know what I mean
because you kind of get a thing where
there's horror movies and there's like
you know certain kind of runs and horror
movies like oh we're gonna do vampire
was but there wasn't really anything
before that I guess blood on Satan's
claw but that was set back in the Middle
Ages because of what they were trying to
do this was more like a work of
philosophy yeah it's really what they're
doing that's true
so although you know I'm looking at it
today I don't know if it's incredibly
deep it's just weird
it's a yeah it is a weird movie and like
I said if you like this type of folk or
I would also recommend like I said blood
on Satan's claw or Witchfinder general
if you haven't seen it I would also
recommend the book harvest home by
Thomas Tryon he also wrote the other
from 1972 was dead yeah that was really
good harvest home they made it into like
a TV miniseries and it's not good but
the book is excellent like the book is
work it's set in the United States but
it's a very similar you know
kind of this isolated town and they're
all sort of pagan E and they have like
all these weird corn in the context of
1973 I think it had a little bit of
different impact because there are a lot
of hippie kids that were getting and oh
yeah that's kind of wicked and crap like
that and this would have been
interesting to them they would oh wow
this is neat but in the end they the
movie tells them that no your shits a
delusion - yeah it's like yeah so I
think it would have had a different
impact back then I think it was a little
bit more culturally relevant you don't
have a bunch of little cults and kids
you know join in hippie cults and Hulme
hippie communes and crap you know that
just doesn't really happen like it used
to yeah so I I think the audiences of
those days would have been more
intrigued or more interested in this yes
I thinked an audience of today would and
Jim will be alienated by this it's not
showing a life that they know there's no
technology in it or anything no social
media yeah because it's retro it's like
showing an Amish community but just a
bunch of them you know yeah but
sometimes that's where the best horror
comes from is it is kind of culture
clash between you know what you think is
the normal world and then suddenly
you're transported back in time and all
these people like living I'm just
totally bizarre that's not what I'm
saying I I don't know young audiences
today they probably don't have the
patience to sit and even watch this
movie
maybe not although I have seen a lot of
like younger critics that seem to like
it
you know so I don't if they're into
movies if they're into film they're in
the philosophy because like I said it's
more an art film art film police
procedural mystery type thing was kind
of a horrific ending rather than like a
traditional horror movie I guess but
it's actually one of my favorite movies
in the 1970s along with like I said
don't look now which it often got paired
with when it was at movie theaters so
we're gonna have to do that one too
also before we go I want to add I did I
only just found out this when I was
researching this show is that the the
infamous well I got don't guess its
infamous but the famous British theme
park Alton Towers has a roller coaster
based on the Wicker Man it has like a
big wicker man that's on fire and
like a rollercoaster goes through it so
if any of you guys have been on it tell
me if it's any good cuz that sounds
awesome but I just that's awesome that
they I love that they made that they
made a rollercoaster based on if that
might be that is [ __ ] up and glorious
alright so that'll do it for our
breakdown of the wicker man from 1973
check it out if you haven't already even
though we've just boiled it but like I
said everybody knows how it ends come on
and remember if you like the show to
like share subscribe and all your social
media if you'd like to financially
supports show you can go to our patreon
page which is patreon.com slash 13
o'clock podcast or you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
WordPress com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to give a one-time donation
remember that our movie retrospectives
come out every Friday our 13 o'clock
matinee three new movies in the theater
that comes out every Sunday and our
regular episodes come out every Tuesday
so check them out we will see you next
time bye